I will do a fundraiser for Trump
I will do a fundraiser for DeSantis I
will do fundraiser for Biden confusing
ain't it and I would bring the same
exact 20 people and I would say see if
you can win these guys over because if
Biden comes to our house and we raise
the money for you tell us what the
number is they're going to say dude this
guy doesn't seem presidential hey that's
what happens but we got you the money
what's the number half a million here's
a half a million the 20 people are going
to go and say dude I thought he was
impressive he's not I liked him but this
guy can't be the president it's not the
case or he's going to say this guy's
pretty impressive this isn't about me
picking favorites right now we need a
fighter today because the war is real
the enemy is massive and they're
unifying during the time like this which
I do believe when I was pushing back on
the four years I do believe this is the
most important time at least in my
lifetime